so things aren't going well and
everybody kept making jokes about what
could happen to us and that was ah the
great outdoors a welcoming place for
some and a very scary place for other
people
hi I'm Lia Zahra and I grew up hiking
camping and even being a Girl Scout but
a lot of my black friends in it but why
well for starters African Americans were
actually legally banned from being in
national and state parks until the Civil
Rights Act of 1964 rude so even if we
wanted to go camping we weren't even
allowed to go so today I'm on a mission
to break down stereotypes of what black
folks don't do and take my friends
camping for their very first time all
right so let's meet our campers I've
never really officially been camping
before I've done like a version of where
we slept by the car at a lake so I
decided to go on this camping trip
because you know captain is actually on
my bucket list of things that I want to
do so my role in this camping trip was
to be the sound and film guy I love
being outside I love camping I have zero
experience with camping because I do not
do the outdoors I was excited to bond
with people like I felt like if we sat
around the campfire you know what I was
really afraid of everything else I'm
accustomed to a certain lifestyle like a
roof over my head and running hot water
and food that I can prepare at a stove I
was being stripped of all of that in the
woods at night like I could die
my fears going into this trip definitely
you were in rattlesnakes
I think just the thought of the idea of
just seen and potentially seeing a snake
in the wilderness while sleeping will
probably be more horrible I signed up
for this but now I'm like
second-guessing this decision well
they're coming rules rule number one you
must build your own shelter well I have
a PhD so YouTube is available well
number two you must storage for your own
food that is either a plant or an animal
like you jerk
that's a damn line I don't know if I can
eat these vegetables and I'm vegan so
rule number three you must build your
own fire without the use of a match or
flames ok yep where are layers how about
that rule number 4 you cannot use your
cell phone it will be completely
disconnected from electronic devices
rule number 5 you'll be provided with
everything that you guys need to survive
in the forest and you must use
everything in the survival pack I know
you're nervous I don't want you to be
nervous and you will be prepared for the
woods in order to prepare my friends for
the woods
guys I have brought in an expert to
teach you you got like a crash course in
camping from Krista survivalist my name
is Christopher Naresh I started the
school of self-reliance about 40 years
ago to teach people about all the skills
that you guys can need on your very
enjoyable trip that's about to come it
was good it was definitely helpful I
think some of the stuff the gentleman
had you know told us about I kind of
reminded myself a remember they brought
the entire trip it was a crash course
because I can't tell you one thing I was
supposed to do he's good me and I did
not feel prepared and it's not that he
did a bad job it's just that I was so
scared that I'm like nope not going on
this trip the car right up there was
cool it was fun cuz I think we were all
like really excited that this thing was
finally gonna happen Wow
it was wildly cramped not enough space
for anyone to breathe and we immediately
started sharing each other's carbon
dioxide which is very poisonous I had so
much anxiety on the car ride over
because I just didn't know what to
expect and the unknown scares me a lot
of the time but above it's not even of a
dog and you just see something creeping
oh yeah it could be a human oh don't
don't be alarmed just
stacy and everybody kept making jokes
about what could happen to us and that
was just felt really bad for asia
cuz this was not feeling it the whole
right up there the whole three hours oh
closer we started to get to the camping
ground the more that reality starts to
set in like i I'm really about to do
this cramping thing and we were told
once we get to like a certain street
corner of the Avenue place that we were
supposed to call this person prior to
getting past it because we would lose
our service and he wasn't answering and
I was like y'all we need to turn around
now
so things already aren't going well imma
met this is Leah from BuzzFeed our group
is about 15 to 20 minutes away we are we
haven't lost reception yet I have five
bars but I wanted to give you a call so
we'll see you soon that's not stressful
at all girl
sir answer your phone come a million
times ain't playing no games about to
hop out the cards and go where so we're
calling no answer calling no answer and
leave those here destiny look maybe you
call and she was like listen to this
police mail and I go to listen to the
voice when the guy goes hello I was very
relieved in the fact that I was not
literally being thrown into the middle
of the woods like it was a very open
place you could see the sky it really
reminds you of the hills and eyes watch
their movie just imagine that scene of
just like in the middle of nowhere
you know just expecting the worst like
some bears some some wild animal just to
jump out of nowhere we were greeted by
the sweetest dogs one of them was Chewie
we were greeted by a guy named Lynette
he is the owner of this property girl so
the property owner gave us a tour of the
land and again everything was really
spread out I am scared to go anyway it
was so many flies so many flies so many
flies I wanted to stay in the car
there was be like a rattlesnake zone I
was totally down for it Te'o was
definitely afraid to see a rattlesnake
and I was really hoping we would see one
just cuz I wanted to know what his
reaction would be like I want to see
this man squeal I see a snake holes soon
as I saw that my guards my eyes my whole
mindset is literally shifted because
every step that I took was just more so
as a snake there is a snake there is a
snake there
yeah so that's the cue when I don't walk
past these lines here
I love how everyone keeps joking about
rattlesnakes I'm not come on aja
snakeskin just laying around somewhere a
freak took us down to the river which
was you know it's colder so it wasn't
that high go towards the edge of like
sort of a cliff and it just like dives
down it's so pretty that's the river
we're gonna take a shower in taking a
shower in the river it looked absolutely
refreshing you just wanted to dive in
and drink it and you can't drink it I'm
not bathing in this river yeah to myself
because I have high anxiety and like I'm
doing it honestly just being here is
brave of me and I feel like everybody
out there is gonna be like why she even
there if she's like not gonna actually
do it this is hard for me it is like I'm
afraid of everything and this Asia ah
bless her heart
I was really worried about homegirl she
didn't want to do this before we left
and I was really surprised that she
followed through I think that she was
definitely gonna have the biggest
challenge on this trip but she was like
very adamant about like I want to do is
I wanna conquer my fears unbeknownst to
me because I'm just the film a sound guy
everyone received a survivalist guide
lesson before the trip I did not so I
had to figure out everything on my own
now I'm just holding this all the
coulomb videos how to purify water now I
won't go to a place if there's not a
good source of water because you cannot
tell by looking at the water if it's
safe to drink if it looks pure and it's
flowing and it's cold that doesn't mean
it's safe and if it's stagnant with a
lot of bugs that doesn't mean it's bad
so you have to have some mechanism for
purifying the water the commercial
filter and all of the biological and
other contaminants are sucked up in here
we really only had a little bit of time
before we lost the Sun so we had to like
complete a lot of tasks and a little bit
of time
about to go dude is that suck water
directly or connect the bottle they're
really troopers I appreciate those
tailing me I'm pretty sure we probably
poisoned them because they tried to
drink through the filter and I sipped
out of the straw and I'm pretty sure I
probably would have gotten Chaconne guy
the instructions I was definitely
jeopardizing my life check it out unlike
the purifier in store we also had water
bottles again legal told me that I had
to give them water we only had a couple
hours to actually complete the tasks we
had to build a shelter we had to start a
fire we had to forage for food and
hopefully never get attacked by an
animal so we've got to build a tent like
right there Oh who's y'all you build in
the tent winners I will supervise you
put the tarp down all right look at you
you're on it you don't get a tent
without instructions follow those
instructions okay it's pretty
self-explanatory what I tell people when
you buy ten and you're at home take it
apart put it together so you're not in
the dark in a funny place so you're
going to ask this boy he said there's
instruction so we put together these
lovely tents that's a lot it was a lot
in his hot owner there's two sources of
food one big source is plants the other
big sources animals native people all
ate the acorns that was a good source of
protein and carbohydrates you can
survive on acorns alone if you don't
want to eat the snakes and fish and
things like that I ain't fighting no
squirrel in a survival situation
anything that flies crawls swims
whatever you can eat the rattlesnake has
the big triangular head so you just you
could avoid that one house on that one
okay you say rattle snake snakes read a
book you just chop off the head you pull
the skin off when you're gonna kill an
animal you don't do it for fun if you're
gonna if you kill it you're gonna eat it
we saw some cactus so no I'm not eating
any fish no raccoon meat so this is a
young cactus pad this particular
paddle-shaped one they're all edible if
you get them young even if it's old and
stiff
you can still peel it and pull the fiber
out and eat it and I want you to tell me
what it tastes like if you find this you
could eat it raw I'll try some too so
you don't think I'm trying to poison you
this is really a superfood with all of
the amino acids and everything it has
you might be lucky enough to find this
when you go up there so no there are no
poisonous cacti Oh Lord it looks like
tails found something what did you have
we come up on some cactus the littler
ones the more recent ones are the ones
that we could use oh no just like
through like butter yes we're gonna put
these cacti over the fire today Te'o and
Asia we're fine though because there
were plenty of cactus to pull from and I
said great y'all pull from that I'll
just starve our guide said that there's
a bunch of gopher here
there's really not a lot and I is
freaking out and I do not want her to
have to help catch an animal of any sort
I was secretly like going to get them
food because I really didn't want them
to starve and I had no idea how hard it
would be to find vegan food the last
part of the day was to actually build
this fire woods to light up and stay
warm tonight because the temperature is
going to drop to 31 degrees so we've got
to stay warm oh I'm so proud it's really
important to be able to make a fire
you're not gonna have matches and
they're not gonna let you have a big
this is a magnesium fire starting tool
and it has a little insert artificial
flint called ferrocerium you guys are
gonna have one when you spark like that
and then when you direct that into some
fine fluff you get a fire starting the
fire was the most fun challenge because
we were all so competitive and
determined to be the one that lit the
fire I get this light going you must
make fire oh we got something
[Music]
No I'm gonna bring it down yeah we need
paper we don't know how to light a fire
with a stick shot unless we really did
so I brought this as a backup I know
it's a break breaking the rules but
we're hungry the bonfire was the best
part of this trip
[Music]
I see Leah with three hot dogs i watch
her stick all three hot dogs directly to
the layman for then leave and I said
those people and they are crisp not even
crisp they are ashed cuz she wanted us
to eat those hot dogs and I said I'm not
eating that hot dog I'm not doing it I
think she tried it she said it tasted
like ash like literally crumbled in her
mouth see what those dogs look like look
at it
they're good you can't deceive you just
a little burnt okay extra crispy what's
pie you dog I'm enjoying this fire and
the heat that's good thank God Aleeah
brought food so we had sandwiches and
not cactus paisa how you don't know
there
[Music]
the whole night I was like I'm never
doing this again never doing this again
never doing this again
[Music]
the boy is freezing you're sleeping on
the floor is one of the worst things
ever it not even just like a nice
pavement it was like you have like a
piece of rock like sticking to your neck
he had another piece of rocks you know
hitting in the back of your lower back
good morning y'all you said your help I
already bought everything you said you
said I don't care I'll go make sure
everybody freezes and all right oh you
sound sick
I feel sick some people might complain I
am a cuddler I was so cold
like literally brought my legs
overanxious body to get warm my booty
I'm just gonna lay here and then my
knees were digging into Destiny's back
no it was not fun it was not a great
experience then we still had like a
bunch of things to do like hack our
lives up and make sure we cleaned up the
campgrounds and shower outdoor shower
and the world than this I thought that
was dope and you're just hearing like
but birds chirping tayo showered first
he's told us that there was hot water
yes I was told beforehand by the women
that the shower was warm enough how's
the shower honestly fried to say like 30
minutes maybe 40 minutes it was just
good it felt good I turned everything on
turn the hot water on let the water run
for a little bit I think I used up all
the hot water maybe that's the reason
why hey buddy yo say hot water it never
got hot it's obviously one of the most
relaxing
moments that I can potentially think of
doing his Cambridgeshire I took a cold
ass shot nautical I took a freezing
shower cuz mind you it was like thirty
something to grieve earlier that day and
my body had never warmed up it was
freezing
it was frigid I felt like spikes on my
skin the soap smelt good which helped me
feel warm people did not know how to run
the hot water I figured it out
and I told them but nobody wanted to
listen anybody's not overall the best
part of this camping trip was bonding
with my co-workers I honestly didn't
really know everyone on this trip very
well because like I'm pretty new to
buzzfeed but it was so nice to like get
to know everybody I think what I really
overcame was like my idea that camping
is just a terrible and nobody should
ever do it Asia was definitely the
character that I was most intrigued by
simply because she shuddered at the mere
word of outside and the whole time we
were there she was miserable and I felt
so bad and I didn't know what to do and
I was like girl help me help you I
surprised myself that I just like I mean
I was pretty confident in that I'd be
able to like survive going through this
well tayo is afraid of snakes so so am I
so I didn't think he would handle it
that well I thought I would do the best
cuz I'm dope you know what I mean I just
know what to do I watched a lot of
Captain Planet growing up actually like
putting him into play and seeing how
miserable people were at certain parts I
felt awful parts where we did have fun
it made the whole trip like worth it I
really did enjoy the fact that like I
got to just be free and be me and not
worry about
oh my hair need to be done a certain
kind of way or I need to look like this
like I could just be like y'all we've
been camping you know what this look
like so really being in I'm gonna live
this moment and enjoy this moment was
the best part of being around the
bonfire and also seeing a stars we saw
all the stars and it was beautiful like
it lit up the sky it was amazing I think
the biggest challenge for me was being
able to coordinate all of these
different
moving parts and keep people fed and
alive like that's a lot
I was literally responsible for like
five human lives but we had a good time
would I do it again probably not but I
think I would take my children camping
so they can experience and decide for
themselves could I go camping again yeah
but I have no desire to hell yeah let's
go let's do it today tomorrow I'm down
next week I would be the first first in
the clip just so y'all know I also quit
before we even started but I made a
promise to Leah I didn't know she was
gonna freeze us to death though an auto
cuddle she cuddled everybody
[Music]
you
[Applause]